one of the biggest worries for families
is energy bills and I pay tribute to my
predecessor the right honorable member
for spellthorne and the former prime
minister the right honorable member for
Southwest Norfolk for their leadership
in this area
this winter we will stick with their
plan to spend 55 billion pounds to help
households and businesses with their
energy bills one of the largest support
plans in Europe
from April we'll continue the energy
price guarantee for a further 12 months
at a higher level of 3 000 pounds per
year for the average household with
prices forecasts to remain elevated
throughout next year this will mean an
average of 500 pounds support for every
household in the country
at the same time for the most vulnerable
we'll introduce additional cost of
living payments next year of 900 pounds
to households or mean-tested benefits
300 pounds to pensioner households and
150 pounds for individuals on disability
benefit
we'll also provide an additional 1
billion pounds of funding to enable a
further 12-month extension to the
household support fund helping local
authorities to assist those who might
otherwise fall through the cracks
and for those households who use
alternative fuels such as heating oil
and LPG to heat their homes I'm today
doubling the amount of support from 100
pounds to 200 pounds which will be
delivered as soon as possible this
winter
and before the end of the year we'll
also bring forward a new targeted
approach to support businesses from next
April